In the previous video, we started working on our ruin.
We took off the roof, and had a better
look at the structure itself.
It's rough and basic.
Patched together brickwork with some additional things
stuffed in there with cement.
It misses some essential structural strength on the bottom,
and the top wall is very weak.
Taking it down is probably cheaper and easier.
But, we like to try and keep as much as possible
of the materials in our existing state.
So, first up is reinforcing.
So, we have a strong base.
So, yeah, welcome to new Project Kamp update!
Let's get started!
So, this is the bottom of the ruin, built out of granite.
Which makes it very strong, and the floor is leaning on top.
Except for this part right here.
This is made from bricks.
Which is not structurally strong enough to hold the entire floor...
So, we need to reinforce this part.
We're going to probably make a metal frame,
to make sure not all the load is on the bricks.
But, actually on a strong frame.
And, the frame would be coming here, on the granite.
So the first thing we're going to do is clean up this edge,
so we can measure it, and make a proper frame.
And, the floor down here, in this room,
is also not leveled at all...
There, it's super low in that corner,
and there it's very high...
So, as we're working with the hammer
to clean up the edge...
We're probably also just going to clean up this one.
And, after that level it, to make sure we have a good base.
So, time to hammer!
All right, so, the stone work is now done.
This edge here is leveled and straight.
So, now, we're going to make a metal frame
that supports the roof!
After we have cut the frame into its size,
it's time to weld it together.
We're using a 12 centimeter H-beam, to carry the load.
It's the thickest, heaviest object
we've made here so far, from metal.
So, taking it down is a bit of a challenge...
Let's see how that goes.
After we managed to carry it down...
We gave it a paintjob, so it's ready to go in.
And, moving it to here was already challenging...
But, what's actually a way bigger challenge
is getting it up that edge...
Mainly because it's just heavy.
But, what made it more challenging,
is that we can't just easily put it on there...
Since it's quite a tight space and gap,
between the edge and the ceiling.
It's like a centimeter, but the whole
ceiling and walls and wobbling and curved...
So, we ask a few hands to help out,
and try to bring the thing into its position.
It worked fine in terms of lifting,
but unfortunately, it didn't fit.
Still some wobbly wall.
So yeah, we needed to bring it down again,
cut it once more and then try it again...
And finally, with the help of all hands on Project Kamp, we made it!
We managed to lift it again, and fit it perfectly.
So, now, we can continue with the renovation.
After the bottom was reinforced, it was time to have
a look at this beautiful brick wall on top.
Hey! Today, we're going to have a look
at this very beautiful wall.
It's very sketchy wall, and it's not stable at all.
And, we want to chop out piece here.
The main reason is because
the wall is already very terrible here.
So, we have to rebuild it anyway.
And, we're going to make space, to insert a sliding door frame,
with a frame from Rita's mom!
So, this would also become
the main entrance of the building.
But, we're a bit scared of that wall,
because it's very unstable at this point...
So, then, I made a very good safety measurement.
It's this sketchy wall, connected to this sketchy wall,
which makes sure they don't fall over.
Don't tighten it too much!
You pull the wall in!
We put a little bit of hardly any tension in it.
And yet, the whole wall is shaking.
So the first thing we got to do is cut a line,
and then brick by brick, we're going to take it down.
Ideally, we save as much as possible,
so we can rebuild some holes.
Tim is getting ready there in the shade.
- I think it's safe, Tim.
- I think it's safe as we can make it!
All right, so, the wall is now out,
and it went surprisingly easy!
I think we almost save all the bricks,
because they were not really stuck.
And, now, at the end of the day,
we're going to cement it a bit back.
The holes in the frame, with the lintel here on top.
But, now, it's going to be too warm...
So, we're going to take a little siesta, and continue.
See you later.
Straight line.
Not a straight line...
Special announcement!
All right, so we are looking for a new video maker!
So, at the beginning of the season,
we had Felix helping us out to make videos for Season 2.
But unfortunately, he has to stop for a few reasons.
Because, it's just heavy on the setting to edit videos.
Flies, it's hot, not a stable office...
But, also, really producing a video each week is quite intense...
He's not used to that.
And, in general, I think also just YouTube comments,
and a lot of opinions can make it hard.
So, unfortunately, he won't be able to continue.
So, we're looking for a new video maker.
We're actually aiming to get to two,
to also just reduce the workload on the video maker itself.
So, this is a request to you guys.
If you're interested in making videos here, come and help out.
Or, maybe your friends that want to come.
And, we wrote an article or a community post on YouTube.
Includes more information, with also the reasons why Felix stopped.
Also, with what we're looking for!
In short, making videos until the end of the season,
which would be November.
And then, until Update 70, so,
you can do the math until when that is.
It will be producing a weekly video.
So, if you're interested, make sure to read that post,
with all the information and a sign-up to help out.
Now: back to the ruin!
So, it's now end of the day, and we're in the shade.
We started cleaning the bricks, to get the old cement off.
They're now here, and Tim it's putting them back together.
So, the frame sticks in there.
So, we built this up with the lintel on top,
and then, it should be good.
Next, we're going to add the windows.
We will add some in the bottom.
So, it's not a dark cave...
And, in the top, to fill the window holes,
that are already there.
And, we got in touch with Ronald.
He had a bunch of glass, and window frames left-over,
from his home renovation, a few years ago.
He gave it to us for our future buildings.
For the ruin, we are going to use the double glass,
and he has a few cool wooden frames for that!
So, here we have some windows!
We have this one, which is a window
with double glass, which is cool!
With the frame, but not the external frame...
So, we would need to make that...
A big door.
And, there is also a whole stack of this double glass!
I think he ordered it, but it was wrong
or something for his house?
So, it's pretty new,
but it doesn't have any framing around it.
We need to find a way to add those.
I think we're going to use this one,
and this one for the ruin.
Our wood tools are not very advanced yet...
So, we brought it to a local wood guy,
to make a frame around it.
And, he made the frames pretty basic:
not angled, and no water drainage in there.
We would think the water would just flow inside...
But, his suggestion was to put the frames under a small angle.
So, the entire frame, and the water then just flows out.
Which, is apparently a very common to do around here.
Bit skeptical about his approach,
but hey, it's a sketchy ruin.
So, let's see!
So, here we have windows that all are already there.
And, our windows that we just made are somewhat fitting...
The height fits in, but they need to have
a few centimeters chopped out...
We're probably going to chop a bit,
on the left and the right.
So, that we can keep the lintel above.
And then, the windows should fit in!
So, before, we were working a lot with the stairs.
Just because that was the only thing we had...
But now, we asked George, our neighbour,
if he has some scaffolding.
So, he borrowed us some very classic,
traditional, Portuguese scaffolding!
A bit rusty, bit heavy,
but this is the thing they use around here!
So yeah, we're going to put it up,
And, from then on, we should be able to work better at a height,
Especially, if we start doing the windows upstairs, and the roof.
Let's puzzle this together!
Safety switches...
Stairs...
Stackable!
A cross that goes in the back...
And, the wooden shelf!
Very safe!
So, next, we're going to do the two windows here on top.
They're going to be slightly different,
because we are first going to put it in a granite frame.
And then, the wooden one,
and it's a bit more of a proper way of doing it.
It's also very common, actually, to do around here.
Because, you find a lot of granite,
and many of the houses here have that frame.
So, we've got some granite,
we got the wooden frames, some cement...
Now, we're just going to build them in here!
All right, so, let me show you the final result!
So, we now have a window that can open,
which creates a good airflow with the door.
Another window here, that gives a good view to the outside.
A reinforced frame, to make sure the whole thing doesn't collapse.
Then on the outside, we have the big hole,
for the big sliding door.
It's not installed yet, because you first
want to do a bit more work on the inside...
And, you might think:
''How do you get into that door?''
So, the plan is to build a bit of a balcony
here in front, so that you can sit outside.
And, this would also be the main entrance.
The main reason also for doing that,
is that this door is just really low...
So, we're going to close this one up,
and then we can also arrange the interior a bit easier.
Over here, we have a window frame from the granite.
All finished, and ready to put in the wood!
It's under a slight angle to make sure the water,
and the rain flows out, and not in...
We already put in a frame,
just so you can see what it looks like.
Yeah, it's very convenient if I look outside,
I look straight at the granite...
A nd, to really see the view,
I just do a bit of bending.
And, next, we also actually wanted to take out this wall!
Because, you have an awesome view back here.
But, we're a bit scared of taking out this one at this point...
Because, it gives strength to that wall,
which is still very fragile.
So, the next step would actually be to build a wooden frame.
And, that makes everything structurally strong,
and connected together.
We're also going to look into the insulation,
on what to do with that...
If you're already on to see the next video,
make sure to subscribe on Patreon, so you can see it!
Or not, and just continue to watch here.
See you next Monday, with the new video!
That was it for this one!
Thanks for watching, and see you next time!
Wanna look at the view?